carros y casas en llamas son imágenes de
las disjordania ocupada un acto de
venganza realizado por colonos israelíes
previamente en la misma zona de jugará
dos israelíes fueron asesinados mientras
conducían un acto terrorista palestino
según el gobierno israelí pero de
momento nadie ha reivindicado la autoría
ante este recrudecimiento de la atención
en los asentamientos Benjamín llamó a la
calma
las fuerzas de defensa de Israel y las
fuerzas de seguridad persiguen
actualmente al asesino encontraremos lo
capturaremos y nos ocuparemos de él les
pido Aunque la sangre siga caliente y
los ánimos caldeados que no se tomen la
justicia por su mano y dejen que las
fuerzas de seguridad hagan su trabajo
en el lado palestino las autoridades han
contabilizado al menos un muerto cercana
blues en esta misma ciudad tuvo lugar
Hace unos días la última de las
numerosas incursiones de las fuerzas
israelíes estos ataques se han
multiplicado
asumió el poder hace dos meses solo
desde principios de este año han muerto
al menos 63 palestinos y 11 israelíes un
recrudecimiento de las tensiones a la
vez que representantes palestinos e
israelíes se han comprometido a una
desescalada en la región tras una
reunión en Jordania